what did it take to become a truck
driver what were the early days like
yeah so this is i mean this is a central
part of the story right that i uncovered
and the the good part was that i went in
without knowing what was going to happen
so i i was able to experience it
as a new truck driver would is one of
the important stories in the book is how
that experience is constructed by
employers to sort of you know help you
think the way that they would like you
to think about the job and about the
industry and about the social relations
of it
um it's super intimidating uh
i say in the book you know pretty handy
guy you know familiar with tools
machines like you know comfortable
operating stuff like from from time i
was a kid
the truck was just like a whole nother
experience i mean as as i think most
people think about it it's this big huge
vehicle right it's
it's really long it's 70 feet long it
can weigh 80 000 pounds
you know it does not stop like a car it
does not turn like a car
um
but at least when i
started um and this this is changing
it's part of the technology story of
trucking
the first thing he had to do was learn
how to shift it
and it doesn't shift
like a manual car the clutch isn't
synchronized so you have to do what's
called double clutch
and it's it's basically the foundational
skill that a truck driver used to have
to learn
um so you would you know accelerate say
you're in first gear
you push in the clutch you pull the
shifter out of first gear you let the
clutch out and then you let the rpms of
the engine drop
an exact amount then you put push the
clutch back in and you put it in second
gear
if your timing is off those gears aren't
going to go together and so
if you're in an intersection you're just
going to get this horrible grinding
sound as you coast you know to a dead
stop in the you know underneath the
stoplight or whatever it is so the first
thing you have to do is learn to shift
it and so
at least for me and a lot of drivers who
are going to
private companies cdl schools what
happens is it's kind of like a boot camp
they ship me three states away from home
send you a bus ticket and say hey we'll
put you up for two weeks you sit in a
classroom you sort of learn the theory
of shifting
the you know theory of kind of how you
fill out your logbook
rules of the road
you know you do that maybe half the day
and then the other half you're in this
giant parking lot with one of these old
trucks and just like you know destroying
what's left of the thing you know just
and it's lurching and belching smoke and
just making horrible noises and like
rattling i mean in these things like
there's a lot of torque and so if you do
manage to get it into gear but the
engine's lugging i mean it can throw you
right out of the seat right so it's this
it's like you know this bull you're
trying to ride and it's super
intimidating um and the thing about it
is that for everybody there
it's almost everybody there it's super
high stakes
so trucking has become
a job of last resort for a lot of people
and so they you know they lose a job
in manufacturing they they get too old
to do construction any longer right the
knees can no longer handle it
um
they get replaced by a machine their job
gets you know offshored and they end up
going to trucking because it's a place
where they can maintain their income and
so
it's super high stress like they've left
their family behind maybe they quit
another job
they're typically being charged a lot of
money so that first couple weeks like
you might get charged eight thousand
dollars by the company that you have to
pay back if you don't get hired
and so the stakes are high and this
machine is huge and it's intimidating
and so it's super stressful i mean i
watched you know men grown men break
down crying about like how they couldn't
go home and
tell their son that they'd been telling
they were gonna you know go become a
long-haul truck driver that they'd
failed and it's kind of this super high
stress system it's designed that way
partly because as one of my trainers
later told me it's basically a two-week
job interview like they're testing you
they're seeing like you know how's this
person gonna respond when it's tough you
know when they have to do the right
thing and it's slow
and you know they need to learn
something are they gonna rush
you know or are they going to kind of
stay calm figure it out you know nose to
the grindstone because when you're in
your truck driver you're unsupervised
you know and that's what they're really
looking for is that kind of
quality of conscientious work
that's going to carry through to the job
well
the truck is such an imposing part of a
traffic scenario yeah so you said like
like turning it it stresses me out every
time i look at a truck because they i
mean the geometry of the problem is so
tricky and so if you combine the fact
that they have to like everybody
basically all the cars in the scene are
staring at the truck and they're waiting
often in frustration
yeah and in that mode you have to then
shift gears
perfectly
and move perfectly and if when you're
new especially
like you'll probably for somebody like
me it feels like it would take years to
become calm and comfortable in that
situation as opposed to be exceptionally
stressed under under the eyes of the
the road everybody looking at you
waiting for you is that the
psychological
pressure of that is that something that
was really difficult yeah absolutely
again just i i saw people freeze up you
know in that intersection as you know
horns are blaring and the truck's
grinding you know gears and you just
can't you know and they and they just
shut down they're like this isn't for me
i can't do it um you're right it takes
years
if you know trucking is not considered a
skilled occupation
but you know my six months there and i i
was a pretty good rookie but when i
finished i was i was still a rookie even
shifting definitely backing
um tight corners and situations i could
drive competently but the difference
between me and someone who had you know
two three years of experience um was
a it was a giant golf between us and
between that and the really skilled
drivers who've been doing it for 20
years
you know is still another step beyond
that so it is highly skilled
you